and we are honored to have him on our
show tonight he joins us now Bobby
thanks so much for coming on
um so you are of course being dismissed
as a vaccine nut but watching your
announcement today it wasn't about
Pharma even so much as it was about
America's place in the world and what do
we do about it if you wouldn't mind
summarizing for our viewers where you
think we are and what you think we ought
to do
well I gave a long speech talk Aaron
thank you again for uh having me on of
course and for that very kind of an
introduction
um you know that I think that the
general theme in my speech was this
corrupt merger of state and corporate
power
which has uh which has gotten uh which
is turning our country into corporate
kleptocracy into a system of socialism
for the rich and this kind of a cushy
socialism for the rich and that's kind
of brutal
um merciless capitalism for the poor
I it keeps us in a state of War it bails
out banks at the same time that it you
know this
month last month the United States
government told 30 million people it was
cutting their welfare their food stamp
checks by 90 percent
it took it took 15 million people off of
Medicare the same month it gave 300
million dollars to the Silicon Valley
Bank and tapped up the cost of the
Ukraine war to 113 billion
we're sending 113 billion to the Ukraine
the entire budget of EPA is 12 billion
the budget of CDC is 11 billion
we have 57 percent of American citizens
could not put their hands on a thousand
dollars if they have an emergency a
quarter of our citizens are hungry so
we're cutting welfare and food stamps by
90 percent
and we're paying and we're bailing out
the bankers we're paying for a war that
you know we we can't afford
and um and with the way that we do this
is by printing money we've printed 10
centuries of money in the last 14 years
and that is that caused the inflation
which raises food by which I would say
tax on the poor
oh you know we've raised food prices for
Basic Foods like chicken Dairy and milk
by 76 percent
in the last two years and now we're
cutting people's food stamps and bailing
out Banks the same month it uh
it doesn't make any sense and we need to
get rid of this kind of corporate
control of our government it comes from
uh this you know it it our our democracy
is devolving into kind of a corporate
plutocracy
I I would think that what you just said
and I I'll just be honest I agree with
most of it but even if I didn't I would
think boy that's a really interesting
thing to say you have a coherent world
view you've written a lot of books on
these topics you clearly thought about
it you're not in it for the money
so don't these issues deserve a wide
hearing uh before the public entering a
presidential year it seems to me that
they do
I would think they would and
particularly the issues of war and you
know my son went over and fought in the
Ukraine as I said today I think where
you know people
the major doyans sort of diplomatic the
most respected diplomatic gurus like
Henry Kissinger and Jack Matlock and
Larry Wilkinson
have all said the Ukraine war is a huge
problem for our country because it from
a geopolitical standpoint
it's driving the Russians close to the
Chinese which is the worst thing for us
but we're there for the right reasons
because we have tremendous compassion
for the Ukrainian people and the illegal
Invasion the brutality and also their
Valor and their courage my own son was
serving over there he joined a Special
Forces Unit as a machine gunner he
fought in the car cave offensive
Americans care about the underdog they
care about that kind of suffering
but the question is why are we in the
Ukraine because Lloyd Austin the
Secretary of Defense
said that were there to exhaust the
Russians President Biden has said that
we're there to to de-platform to depose
Vladimir Putin and if that's why we're
there and we're killing a lot of
ukrainians as Pawns
in a proxy orbitude between two great
powers
here's one last thing I would say
nobody talks about this there's 14 000
Ukrainian civilians who have died but
300 000 troops the Russians are killing
ukrainians at a seven to one to eight to
one ratio they cannot sustain this well
we're being told about this war is just
not true
no it's not true and I would hope
despite the fact you criticize their
advertisers other media Outlets would
have enough respect for our country and
for its voters to give what you said a
hearing because I think it's really
important and we're again grateful that
you came on our show tonight you're
always welcome Bobby Kennedy Jr thank
you
thank you very much doctor
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight